Christmas and Happy Hanukkah WAPA he's
Jewish you know that you didn't know
that so sweaters back and I said dumber
than ever when the time is right and the
people already the sweater shall return
Christmas is the right time we are ready
for sock puppets that seem to have no
eyes they're blind puppets that's sad
I'm well he's got to have it he's there
looks like - I bet there's like a face
inside his mouth that's kind of creepy
I was rejected from glove storia sock
opera okay I tried to audition but they
said I didn't look the part right says
suckas cuz you're black isn't haha and
blind and toothless so sad
basic has a story he doesn't own any
white side I have why having all Dwyers
socks I have a pair that's about it uh I
hope these are clean
another clean they're just no is what
you're like you know are they used I'm
like well they're all used I mean but
they're clean um so okay so this uh
there's a lots to say about this episode
this is one where uh navel comes across
this this puppeteer who is way too
obsessed with his hobby and it's her
crush of the week so she decides to put
on this puppet show to try and Gabe but
bill cipher returns uh which is a big
deal in one of my favorite things is
that remember I saw the window of the
triangle on the window with the eye and
I'm like oh come on they put that there
just I think I haven't come out but when
I looked at all the other episodes that
that I in that triangle was always there
in the window I'm like holy crap like I
can't believe I never noticed that
oh well played gravity falls yeah so uh
so bill cipher comes out says he'll help
him get into the computer the briefcase
that's come back in the play uh he just
wants to use a puppet for a amount of
time he's like oh okay think it's gonna
be one the side puppets oh you're my
puppet easy me buddy do i I love how I
can be again just so stick
Fanning but
it's also intimidating yeah he's really
intimidating the second he came back I
was like oh no oh dear god no he's
probably the scariest thing I've seen
this whole freakin show it's just so
us he's so like he's got a really
high-pitched voice a makes all these
lame puns and said I'll forget about it
sup but he's also so scary it'sit's such
a he really is like getting into that
sense it's such a fascinating combo oh
it's such a ridiculous design but it's
it is creepy
um so I'm really thinking that's what
they were um you know the bunker and
everything that that's what they're
defending against you know like him or
some like version of him or something
connected to him because he always
talked about the end and stuff oh that's
a I forgot to actually say what the
because we're in stuff so he um so if
there's a great scenery brings up how
maple never like uh you know mayor that
this is a Christmas thing though maple
maple maple Maybelle me bail me do uh
says how breaks up how she's never
sacrifice anything even though dippers
sacrifice a lot which is kind of a legit
point it's not like she's useless but
it's like she hasn't really given up
that much so this is her episode where
she gives up the plague love story a
sock opera to help tip her out is it sad
that I would totally see that show I
want to see somebody put that show on if
the amazing like we should do that some
point somehow just after after watching
like what she had going on there I'm
like this is amazing I would totally I
would paint always see this I would make
that if I'm going off to war I was just
no war um sorry so the lot of funny
little things here a lot of messages is
we've all had a lot of fun tonight but
let's not forget who the real puppet
masters are Reptoids we've infiltrated
our government so be on lookout for
Reptoids and uh uh Ernie that means one
of the agents from earlier is a Reptoid
maybe oh um just put my sock your sock -
yeah this it's clean ish uh uh and then
if I light no puppets drinks can hold me
down so
patiently I watched this town and normal
soon will be the norm enjoy the calm
before the storm so nice and cryptic
spooky yeah so a lot of funny jokes I
will save this um I've been reading the
biography of Jim Henson and I know there
is sort of like this remiss stuff like
I'm not like really into puppetry but I
appreciate the hell out of it cuz I'm
like I'm so amazed what people can do
with it but the same time it's like I'd
be lying if what I heard somebody's like
I'm into puppeteering and stuff you you
um your gut reaction first is really but
then when you see like how good they are
whatever like pocket well is with the
puppet hey no no no I think everyone has
sort of like in their minds are like the
stereotype of this guy of Gabe in this
like you know yeah what do you do with
those puppets vide you've loved a lot
but it's like it's an amazing craft so a
part of me sort of feels bad I like a
stereotype I just assumed he was just
way over the top of it
oh no but I think that like a white boy
who collect toys don't always sit there
and like you know talk to their toys
creepily no but that's not that no but
exactly you have that thought to like
you know people collect toys and thereby
we know people to collect toys and stuff
but it's like initial reaction is kind
of like going to the extreme like he's
not this extreme is he or something like
that but so when I see this I do sort of
like feel bad almost for laughing at him
but I think it is just the idea of like
it's a hobby taken to an extreme you
know you're making out with the puppets
and stuff like that so just all
puppeteers out there just do good work
man you're a go um it's only because
I've every the Jim Hanson biography and
he's amazing
oh that was some amazing tap dancing
there no no but it's like cuz the
stereotype of the creepy puppet guy but
I like puppeteering work this is no it
no cuz it is amazing it is one of those
things but it's like I know what they're
talking about when like you see someone
doing like that extreme it's like you
know it's just cuz you don't know much
about it I don't know much about
puppeteering but why do you have to hate
yeah I don't know why anyone would get
an idea that puppeteers are creepy or
weird like at all okay I mean I don't
know why anyone would get that idea um
but yo just cuz I'm having fun that's
gonna be like a new frame
isn't it yeah okay good for you you just
just hate everything
I don't hate everything you're just
afraid of everything and can you blame
me the way you're dressed
Shari anywho um okay so a couple things
really sit first of all we had to like
rewind and pause with the very first
joke which is the oh my god read it's a
full book reading oh look and they're
going to yelling at each other
I didn't see me though it said reading
with a bigger yeah it was like just the
biggest what the poster and it was
so funny I mean I was learning like like
I had to pause it because I was laughing
so hard it's just one of those what the
hell and it just goes by so quickly
you're just your brain just trying to
comprehend what you just saw because it
was so straight yeah you get monster
together I like how the little computer
has a bandaid on it for that little good
mounsieur thing I was gonna say yeah I'm
wondering on the guck ik connection
maybe oh because he is the Bandidos
beard and that does almost awesome I
just put a thing on it so could be I
don't know um they were reveal anything
yet that I know um so I love I love the
poster it just says learn earth just
very basic just blurt earth like learn
the world or whatever um let's see I
like that
Gabe where is only one wearing a tux to
the premiere cuz it's such a big deal
with by the way Thea's puppet still love
it yeah that's okay but the biggest
thing right now okay so there's a scene
where uh they're so on the puppet
together and stuff and on the sewing
machine it says so what okay cute little
joke well guess what that joke this is a
comic I drew when I was like a 14 years
old and it was bat mouse return see that
there's rat woman and I drawn both sides
because I there was no technology back
then for this that I could afford and
when she's playing her outfit together
it goes to her sewing acquittal what's
that say let's just say it's probably
too blurry you can't see a focus goddamn
you okay it says sewing so what yeah
yes yes me and gravity falls think alike
and that is why I deserve to be a part
of this show because deep down inside
you want me on that fault you need me on
that false I use words like so and what
you use a man like defending Disney I
use them as a punchline
I am your time nor the effort to explain
myself to people who rise and sleep
under the blanket of hilarity that I
provide and that doesn't even realize
that I'm providing it
I heard you just said thank you and
acknowledge me otherwise I suggest you
pick up a computer and start writing
more puns either way you don't give a
damn what I think that I'm entitled to
and you say I'm weird at no just no
actually wonder what the creepy thing is
it has a face guy it has a face I don't
know if you can see it see if you can
hold it up like really close there
actually it's like two eyes and about it
is kind of from where you wore the sock
out yeah probably up throw that I put my
lips on it I think I'm definitely gonna
wear that out it's a sweater I'm telling
you it's the sweater it does things
makes me do things we've had all sorts
of Christmas wrongness here um sniffs
nah it's like that thing from explores
that smells them this amazing movie see
that but we go we're ain't so psyched
right okay that's what that's what
puppetry does man so puppetry does
puppetry in the sweater combined it's
like what yes um I have no hands and I
must scream I think that's all the
reason we're gonna get out of this
episode so it's a funny episode of goes
very funny yeah good combination of a
good jokes and learning more about the
about the backstory no redemption for
Mabel whoo yeah can be bit selfish
occasionally yeah but as much as she's
right she can also be selfish I admit it
I I mean she admits it um so but she
comes back and the explosion of the
puppets and Gabe
crying what's happening
great um so and I like that again I love
it when they just pretty much say the
cliche they're gonna try and doing that
doesn't follow through I've seen enough
movies to know everyone thinks it's part
of the show and they all applaud there
were just booths like the hell out of it
which I wouldn't boo that blows amazing
oh and I was by the road with the
grunkle Stan puppet flying through the
air and Fire Oh Oh with the they've
done a lot of reflection uh imagery with
dipper and for first when he was frozen
oh when the change I mean when Windows
goes and then the window yellow bill
cipher and the window goes up each sees
his face over his face which is I I
don't think they're trying to imply
anything with that I think it's just a
cool visual and it makes it more
traumatic but yeah I wonder if some
serve like oh these damn noodley limbs
oh yeah I love it
I love that the big downfall bill cipher
is that the body is just hot yeah it's a
new week and sweaty and gets tired too
fast
Mabel's gotta fly know your weakness I
like posing uh ed maple say I've got a
full night's rest huh three shots of
Mabel 200 is my other favorite line it's
like if coffee and nightmares had a baby
so yeah a very funny episode
I can't think it too much else to say
about it um just a a lot of fun good
mysteries and need me on that show
somehow make it work or I can just keep
doing V logs because I love watching the
show but either way you need me on that
falls hey Doug what did the one hand
puppet say to the other I don't know let
me give you a hand
Merry Christmas and Happy Hanukkah wha
pannonica happy you know in here Kissin
Christmas ever
just turn it off turn it off Abbi wanna
go